nous ont rejoint sur notre plateau Yann
Crouzat bonjour bonjour PDG de l'accord
complètement et Lionel Thomas directeur
général d'intermès bonjour bonjour
Nicolas bonjour Patrice bonjour
on est très heureux de vous avoir
ensemble parce que il y a d'un côté une
startup d'un côté une entreprise et une
entreprise qui investit dans les
startups c'est ça oui c'est ça c'est ça
internet c'est une belle PME créée en
1989 et sous l'impulsion de son
président fondateur Charles Casanova
nous nous sommes investis à développer
l'entreprise autour de trois grandes
thématiques la première qui était
importante pour nous c'était de ne pas
oublier de nous venons et de continuer à
servir au mieux nos clients français la
seconde c'était de nous développer à
l'export parce que
comme l'a dit précédemment le directeur
délégué de BPI France il est stratégique
pour les entreprises de taille moyenne
de taille intermédiaire de
[Musique]
une entreprise qui a une trentaine
d'années un peu moins
dans l'innovation alors il y a ça se
passe comment vous avez beaucoup de
recherches beaucoup de d'innovations
justement alors comment ça se passe
parce que
doigts petit à petit dans le
développement de l'entreprise a
rapidement
le président Charles Casanova souhaitait
développer en fait à département R&D qui
nous a permis de développer de toute
nouvelle technologie basée en fait sur
des sous-ensembles de produits qui
constituent nos systèmes développés et
produits pour les applications
internationales alors Yann cruso vous
avez créé votre start-up en 2018 mais au
début vous étiez pas vous aviez pas
cette vocation à devenir entrepreneur et
effectivement un parcours qui n'est pas
commun à tout le monde après 23 ans de
police nationale effectivement j'ai eu
la chance de de passer par les CRS
pendant 6 ans et puis j'ai eu la chance
aussi de d'intégrer le une unité un peu
d'élite le service la protection de
notre personnalité le groupe de sécurité
du président de la République et j'ai
pris une disponibilité comme nous le
permet l'administration
cette année au mois d'avril pour
reprendre la présidence de l'accord
puisque c'est une société effectivement
qu'on a développé avec Vincent
charpentier qu'au fondateur en 2018
poste attentat puisque l'idée nous est
venu quelque part de développer un
concept un peu particulier pour pouvoir
fluidifier les flux puisqu'à l'époque
vous rappelez suite aux attentats vous
payez une heure une heure et demie qui
était bien présent sur ces zones là et
on a réfléchi à pouvoir concevoir un
concept mobile intégrant des
technologies mais je pense qu'on en
parlera un peu plus tard mais justement
cette technologie effectivement
alors vous avez l'idée mais après
comment vous faites une vraie passion
pour le sport automobile m'a permis de
réfléchir sur un système un peu comme
motorhome vous savez si semi-remorque
qui se déploie avec pour l'intégration
de différentes technologies déjà réglées
en son intérieur mais il fallait
raconter une histoire une histoire qui
allait nous permettre d'être suivi par
le ministère de l'Intérieur et entendu
donc on s'est appuyé sur des
référentiels notamment le guide de la
sûreté de la sécurité événementielle qui
nous permet derrière d'avoir l'écoute du
secteur étatique et bien sûr le soutien
de privé et tout un réseau d'incubateurs
Réseau Entreprendre 78 Sky club
incubalians qui nous a permis de nous
rencontrer avec des amis communs et j'ai
quatre générates sur Paris donc qui
rassemble les plus grosses sociétés de
sûreté et de défense française dont
internet fait partie mais il a fait du
chercheur des ingénieurs aussi pour
mettre au poids tout ça alors oui
effectivement on a on a toutes ces idées
il a fallu mettre un peu voilà
qu'il a toucher du doigt et brick après
brick on a déjà déposé les brevets conçu
toute cette enveloppe puisque l'accord
notre point fort c'est pouvoir à travers
des concepts mobiles et transportables
donc de pouvoir contrôler le public à
une certaine distance des événements de
façon à faire en sorte que si jamais il
y avait un acte de malveillance que le
site en question et le public déjà à
l'intérieur ne soient pas impactés donc
on est dans une politique de protection
mais une protection pour tous en tout
lieu et accessible à tous et alors votre
produit est mise au point vous avez
présenté je suppose votre prototype à
atermès et puis internet a décidé de
rentrer dans votre capital en juin
dernier c'est tout récent quel a été
votre stratégie du côté d'intermès
pourquoi vous êtes intéressé à l'accord
parce que d'abord la société l'accord a
des besoins industriels autour de
l'intégration de ces technologies pour
réaliser un produit ça nécessite en fait
de maîtriser une supply chaîne des
achats avec des partenaires ça nécessite
en fait de construire des étapes
d'intégration avec des contrôles
interopérations avec un certain nombre
de fonctions logicielles embarquées qui
sont qui nécessitent en fait de mettre
en oeuvre des compétences
d'industrialisation très particulières
et nous disposons en fait de tous ces
moyens et de toutes ces capacités dans
notre site industriel voilà et ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que l'accord
aussi
fabrique quelque chose que vous ne
saviez pas faire ou alors ça veut dire
que
l'idée originelle en effet nous nous
l'avons pas eu et bien heureusement il
existe en fait des startups des sociétés
comme l'accord qui ont des idées
originales et qui doivent être
développés mis en oeuvre mais ça
nécessite forcément des capacités
industrielles et c'est très difficile en
fait pour des startups de la taille de
l'accord au départ de la création d'une
telle entreprise deux trois personnes il
est inimaginable de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre de telle techno donc nous à terme
est-ce nous proposons de mettre à
disposition cet outil industriel
d'industrialiser en fait des produits
avec eux de les accompagner également en
leur offrant le toit ne serait-ce que ça
d'abord quelque chose qui est important
donc les abriter partager un certain
nombre de compétences de services
transverses qui sont nécessaires de la
qualité des fonctions achats des
fonctions administratives et financières
qui permettent à une entreprise de se
développer et puis de proposer à ses
clients un produit achevé industrialisé
qualifié et pertinent et performant et
c'est une réelle opportunité pour eux
puisqu'en plus vous avez déjà beaucoup
de clients et puis il y a les
perspectives des Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 effectivement il y a une
vraie demande surtout en ce moment je
sais pas ce qui se passe tant mieux
peut-être effectivement l'arrivée de la
Coupe du monde de rugby et des JO 2024
et puis il faut pas excusez-moi sans
lever de l'esprit de la menace bien sûr
qui qui
est toujours là et on se doit d'être
vigilant voilà après le rapprochement
pour nous l'accord à terme c'est pour
nous une vraie chance parce que
effectivement c'est une épaule il y a du
savoir-faire il y a les idées je vais
pas dire que c'est mieux que des
business Suns Angel ou comme font mais
effectivement on va pouvoir développer
un vrai savoir-faire et un partage créer
des passerelles et puis il y a
bienveillance parce que ça reste une
grosse PME mais quand j'ai besoin de
d'aller à poil à la porte de Charles
Casanova de Lionel mais la porte est
ouverte je veux dire ça prend pas six
mois pour avoir un retour et ça pour une
start-up c'est important on doit avoir
un retour immédiat ce qui est vrai le
lundi ne l'est plus le mardi on avait
Christophe Cousin tout à l'heure qui est
le président de gwenwin et celle-là
c'est win-win c'est gagnant-gagnant quoi
c'était complètement comme ça l'accord
travaille avec Gwen win effectivement
aussi et alors vous avez eu évidemment
l'aide de la BPI l'aide de la Région
l'aide de Sky club aussi complètement le
le schéma type l'accord et le
schématique d'une startup qui a émigré
en tous les cas qui développait sur le
secteur de 50 ans comme je vous disais
raison entreprendre 78 nous a fait
confiance avec un premier prêt d'honneur
derrière deux business angels
obligatoirement doivent rentrer mais on
a eu on c'est lauréat aussi de dinove up
spécial et Jo 2024 qui nous a permis
d'avoir une subvention de la Région de
la région et un pré BPI donc ils
viennent compléter tout ça avec les
banques avec la BNP mais on a aussi eu
la chance d'être accompagné par Thalès
dès le départ puisque notre idée les a
séduites et ils nous ont financé notre
poke la preuve de concept qu'on a
développé à Polytechnique au tout début
donc le chemin était long et se met dans
bûche avec la covid justement peut-être
une dernière question à Lionel Thomas en
terme de stratégie d'entreprise quand
vous voyez que l'accord a quand même
travaillé avec Thalès auparavant est-ce
que ça vous a pas fait peur vous en tant
que PME parce que vous avez pas les
mêmes infrastructures et même structures
que Thalès d'investir de vous investir
auprès de l'accord en vous disant que
peut-être que Thalès va en bénéficier
aussi pas du tout pas du tout c'est
aucune peur de ce côté là d'abord parce
que cette transparence en fait sur ce
qui a permis à l'accord de se développer
dès le départ elle a été clairement
affirmée dès le début dès le premier
rencontre parce
qui a une il y a de quoi gagner quoi oui
une vraie envie de réussir et de partage
parce que là on ira pas sans l'autre
dynamique allez et bien merci à tous les
deux c'est devenu sur ce plateau merci
beaucoup et à très bientôt à très
bientôt merci parce qu'on continue
justement Nicolas parlait des JO on aura
l'occasion de se revoir
dans notre condition mais avec grand
plaisir avec grand plaisir cette édition
spéciale du skycose poursuit Patrice on
va parler de cybersécurité il faut il
faut nécessaire
[Musique]